uh we have been seeing mass shooting
after mass shooting after mass shooting
make national headlines recently
and we have polling that suggests to us
hey you know what americans really are
hungry for some gun safety regulations
they they want them and uh there is a
very interesting a poll from pew
research compiled by vox and we're going
to put a vox graphic up on the screen
and when you look nationally
yes led by democrats but republicans
also we see greater than 85 percent
support for some mental health
restrictions on who can own firearms we
see more than 80 support for background
checks what we would call universal
background checks meaning there is no
situation where a gun is sold that would
be exempt from a background check we see
about 78 of the country against open
carry without a permit there are some
states where you can open carry with no
permit and even the less popular stuff
like banning assault style weapons or
banning high-capacity magazines even
those provisions have close to
two-thirds support right around 65
percent
so very clearly republicans have seen
the polling republicans are now
understanding hey a lot of these things
are popular with americans
we as republicans can't just be the
party of saying do nothing arm teachers
and eliminate doors or whatever they've
been talking about so now mitch
mcconnell and some other republicans are
saying you know we are we are okay we're
supportive
of the framework that's been established
for this senate gun safety deal so we're
gonna look at a clip but i have to tell
you
i am so skeptical of everything that's
going on here on both sides and i'll
explain all of that in a moment but
here's mitch mcconnell yesterday making
headlines wow
republicans being reasonable they
support
wait do they support the bill or they do
they support the framework well that's a
key distinction take a listen to this
senate cornin who as you know i asked to
be the point person on our side to see
if we could
come to
an outcome
after these horrible school shootings
and his
teammates
indicated as you have reported
are coming together but kind of behind a
framework
which hopefully can be turned into
legislative
language and past
for myself i'm comfortable with the
framework and if the legislation ends up
reflecting
what
the framework
indicates
i'll be supportive
right
so a number of ifs in there right i'm
supportive of the framework
which
hopefully will get us to a bill and if
the legislation reflects what's in the
framework then it is hopefully something
that we can support
now there's two sides to this this is a
great opportunity for republicans to say
this and then oppose it either because
well the legislation ended up being
different than the framework or were
disappointed in what democrats
ultimately put here uh but there's
another aspect to this which is the bill
itself
is pretty damn crappy now i don't want
to just
listen i i am not i am okay with
incremental change and taking steps in
the right direction and if this is all
that can be passed well we've got to
pass it i'm going to tell you what's in
this framework
but it is pretty damn weak very very
weak
um there are a few different things here
so first of all there are red flag
provisions that um
are in the framework meaning
that you have a process
that will allow you to do sort of some
kind of of um uh
for those individuals who are believed
to have mental health conditions that
should prevent them from having a
firearm this is a framework that would
allow some of those to be established
there are 19 states in washington d.c
that already have some version of that
and that's something that would be in
the bill and listen republicans have
been talking about this is a mental
health issue so that's something they're
generally supportive of although some
republicans are saying you're kind of
eliminating due process instead of
actually saying well
you are now a felon and you can't have a
firearm which would be due process
some republicans are against these red
flag laws saying you're basically just
saying some psychologist can sign off
and then you don't you don't get your
constitutional right to a firearm so
that could be a problem they want a more
rigorous process for background checks
specifically on people between 18 and 21
which would include an enhanced review
where you contact state and local law
enforcement if you have criminal records
it could be disqualifying there's a
proposal
about
who should have to register as a
firearms dealer for the purposes of
conducting background checks there's
some squishiness to that where you can
be a dealer you and i would look at it
and we would say this is a dealer but
they don't currently have to register as
such and thus don't have to
comply with background checks laws there
should be no question of that every sale
should require a background check no
matter where it happens they also want
new penalties on straw purchasing of
firearms to improve the prosecution of
traffickers this is where someone who
can legally get guns buys a bunch of
them and then sells them to people who
cannot legally get guns those are called
straw purchases and then they want money
for mental health services as well so
there's nothing remotely controversial
here in the framework any sane country
would do all of these things and much
more
but that's exactly the problem number
one
the bill is so milk toast that it
doesn't do
almost any of the things that i outlined
in my framework for what should be done
and at the same time republicans still
might not support it so this is yet
again it's a good chance
maybe to show that republicans will
block even the weakest
gun safety provisions
but at the same time maybe republicans
will support it because it does so
little and then they can say look the
democrats put together a bill we
supported it and we still have gun
violence which of course we would have
because this bill has absolutely no
teeth so
it i i hate to say it
it all seems like it's a great setup for
the republican party here's a bonus clip
here's mitch mcconnell being asked why
people who can't legally buy cigarettes
should be able to buy semi-automatic
weapons mitch mcconnell supported
raising the age at which you can buy
tobacco from 18 to 21 and mitch
mcconnell does not answer why should
americans who are 18 years old not be
allowed to buy cigarettes which is
something you support that
should be allowed to buy
good try
i've already told you
my view not really a try it's a good
question framework
if it leads
to a piece of legislation
i intend to support it i think it's
progress for the country
and i think that
the bipartisan group has done the best
they can
to get total support
and the background
check enhancement for that age group i
think is a step in the right direction
yeah it's it's so weak a background
check enhancement just for those 18 to
21. so mitch not falling for any trick
questions like why should you be able to
get an ar-15 but not cigarettes which is
really not a trick question it's a good
question
let me know what you think is the fate
of this bill find me on twitter at
dpakman we'll take a quick break and be
right back
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uhler and cube sleep systems and 10
off the new dock pro this offer is only
for my audience the link is down below